some good news tonight about the kobit
19 vaccine in our state
delayed doses have arrived which means
more appointments are available
thanks for joining us at 11 i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis our state
also
no longer near the bottom of the list in
terms of vaccines administered
orco mana joining us live to break all
of this down for us
orco well brian and denise nevada's kova
19 vaccination dashboard
shows that more than 550 000 nevadans as
of sunday
have gotten the vaccine and just by
looking at the 14 day moving average
it's clear we are administering more and
more doses
and even as delayed shipments arrive
more vaccines are needed
we're hoping that we'll get really
caught up this week the southern nevada
health district adding first dose
appointments this wednesday to saturday
at cashman center including for 65 to 69
year olds this after receiving a
modernist shipment which was delayed by
severe weather we were really only
planning to do second dose
but since we have that capacity and we
have the vaccine we'd like to get
at least a few doses in for this week
the city of north las vegas also making
some first dose appointments available
this week more good news
new cdc data shows nevada ranks 35th out
of all 50 states when it comes to
vaccines administered per capita
but state health officials are still
trying to get more we're continuing to
request
formal response on the formula itself
and continuing to work with our federal
delegation and federal partners to
receive that
experts say if johnson johnson's vaccine
gets emergency use authorization
having that third option would be
beneficial i think that's really going
to help us
accelerate through the priority groups
and hopefully get to the point where we
can do general population
sometime in either may or june
but with so much work still to do the
timeline is uncertain
we really have not put that much of a
dent into the
over 70 groups so we'll probably be
there for a while
the southern nevada health district is
also setting up a special clinic at its
offices
for people who have mobility issues just
call or
email the district and we have all that
information on the web story for
this story on eight news now dot com
reporting live tonight orco mana 8 news
now